Eli Manning has been announced that he's
back as the starter Giants are gonna go
back to Eli Manning Adam Schefter
according to Jordan renin who I believe
is a reporter covering the Giants Steve
Mariucci my compadre on NFL gameday
morning and he'll be there with all of
us in Atlanta for a big Saints Falcons
game to kick-off week 14 back here on
the show Steve what do you think of the
McAdoo News well a couple things rich I
thought we might talk about cookies for
the first five minutes because those
Oreos you know you got all kinds of
flavors and I like them all that's why
Baskin Robbins has 31 plates all right
guys varieties spice of life last night
I'm not going to Atlanta with you guys
there was a scheduling snafu or some
dancing I went what what I wanted to see
that new stadium sit next to rich and
he's and he says no he's got a different
thing on us anyway it's all out of whack
I'll be watching you from home again
go ahead boy he sounds like you got is a
voice Steve you okay it's a you / thing
company right yeah okay all right so
here we go with Eli starting again oh my
god what a mess what a mess and you know
what but this isn't like the first mess
it's not a most recent mess either
because I thought it was messy when they
got rid of a Hall of Fame coach and Tom
Coughlin think about it two years ago
and then and then really eventually Tom
Coughlin is going to be in the Hall of
Fame having won two Super Bowls over
there and all of that and he's doing his
magic down in Jacksonville and then you
hire somebody from his staff what does
that tell you what does that mean if you
want to change you go outside you don't
you don't hire somebody from staff with
no experience and then and then Ben
McAdoo starts off 11 and 5 and goes to
the playoffs and everybody goes ok all
right we have a we have a new hire here
that gets it and then well and Jerry
Reese gets let go today and he's had
some success it doesn't matter how we
got there
you know everybody climbs a ladder in
some way shape or form and and under his
watch they've been successful not
recently their rosters a little out of
whack they spent 200 million dollars on
defense that didn't show up this year so
it's always a set of circumstances as
well you know the Giants office is
second worst in the league and it's not
because Ben McAdoo's an idiot it's
because they got four receivers hurt and
in a series of a short period of time
and didn't get them all back in
offensive line issues the whole thing
and it's never any one person's fault
it's a culmination of things but I think
this was the straw that broke the
camel's back it was the mishandling of a
great icon in a lion and so they just
can't deal with it so what do you think
if you could give your best guess I said
this on the air yesterday when we had
this conversation right around around
11:15 Eastern Time I'm like there's
still four hours to put Eli in the game
it's not as if there's a game plan
that's completely different that Eli
wasn't sitting there for all of it that
he wasn't running scout team for some of
it that if you were planning on firing a
coach over this or you or you feel that
the coach should be considered untenable
because you want to put a lie back in at
this late stage in the game don't want
to just do it and and that's it and then
so the guy who has to stand there on the
sidelines feeling like the world's
crashing down is the guy that you're
firing the next day anyway not your
all-time great quarterback
what happened do you think can you know
it's hard to backtrack once a coach
makes a statement publicly you don't
want to you know you don't want to be a
liar and you yeah he Ben
McAdoo had a go with his plan he said he
was going to start Geno and he'll I was
going to be the backup and he was going
to wear sunglasses and that was it
and that's what they did and the camera
was on île a whole game I just felt bad
for him and he Eli's such a study I mean
he handled that he takes the high road
you know he's had 210 games that's he
started in a row but he's got a thousand
press conferences that he's been an
absolute Pro and an absolute New York
Football Giants to the max I've never
seen him throw anybody under the bus
he's been perfect and and so unfortunate
now he's got to go play he's got to go
play again and I don't know how you do
that it's the fans are certainly going
to cheer him like crazy I know
give the Cowboys Cowboys Cowboys are
like you sure you don't want to start
Davis whatever genome or sometimes when
you shake a team up like this it
midstream the players wake up it's like
oh alright I'm next if we don't pick it
up here and this team might really show
up who knows all right Steve Mariucci
joining me here for a few more minutes
and Monday's with Moochie here in the
Rich Eisen show let me just quickly run
through it for because I know you're not
you're not going to coach the Giants I I
pounded the table I said David Shaw will
be the perfect guy what do you think ooh
perfect you know and we all like David
Shaw and we're all friends with David
Shaw and he's really good he's really
solid not just as a coach but as a guy
and a family man all of that I don't I'm
not sure if New York's his cup of tea he
really likes it out here rich he really
really likes it here at Stanford and
they're paying him good and he's in he's
in control of who we recruits and it's
like next statement told me because I
asked Nick you can ever go back to nano
so he goes mooch he says in the NFL you
take turns drafting you take turns with
32 teams drafting so you get one first
rounder a year that's it he says when I
recruit I can get as many as I can get I
can get three four or five maybe that's
what Nick said and he says and so uh
that's how you know that's create some
stability doesn't it and so David Shaw's
got a role in at Stanford right now and
and I don't know if he would do that now
if I were a general manager yep
somewhere in the league I'm calling
David Shaw there's no doubt I'm calling
David Shaw to find out what his interest
is and because he's you know he's got
some experience with the NFL and he gets
it he comes from a coaching lineage all
right then let's hit a couple other
items well I still have you here what do
you take out of a Sunday night win for
Seattle over Philadelphia for either
team what do you take out of that Steve
well I you know what I was as surprised
as most people we all thought did we not
did we all thought that the Philadelphia
Eagles we're going to play their game
like they've been and go in and steal
one right in front of the 12 but you
know what they couldn't tackle Russell
Wilson couldn't yeah
and you know Fran Tarkenton rich played
before you were born but I remember that
guy when I was a kid and we're in my
team the Packers are chasing that guy
around got some he's always running
around and that's Russell Wilson you
can't tackle that guy and he may if they
don't have Russell Wilson forget about
it in Seattle I mean that with all due
respect Pete's staff and John Snyder and
the rest of that team terrific terrific
but Russell Wilson's magic and and he
did his thing and you know Carson
Wentz's fumble didn't help going in and
you know some of those things but this
just tightened it up in the NFC it
really did yeah when you say didn't we
all think that I'll give you the answer
no we did not all think that only one of
us it happened less than 24 hours ago
Steve why would you draw a blank on that
here's what I think is it that's a tough
place to win in December it okay and and
and once though I mean that throw when
he was wrapped up without using his legs
and his upper body and arm
what was that 40 45 yards in the air
yeah there being a 51 yard completion
yeah are you tired driving that far I
mean I mean come on I was watching the
game and enjoying it because you know I
did a little thing remember many moods
yesterday was on those two guys running
around making place like that right and
it's just a it's just a thrill to watch
those kids play and their unconventional
their their athletes they're running
around like crazy man
forget about all the fundamentals you
just find a way to make a play and both
of those guys were going back and forth
and it was just so entertaining I love
watching that stuff what do you think of
Brady barking at McDaniels like he was
Bill alive right with Bill O'Brien
remember me oh yeah what do you think of
that he can get a little snippy
sometimes I love that edge he's got and
have you have you learned anything about
it today what they're talking about
well here's the thing is that if another
quarterback does it we're going nutty
over this right Steve
I mean Big Ben's doing this with even
you can't even just say well he's
one XYZ I mean big Bennett is a two-time
Super Bowl champion he does this with
Todd Haley tonight on Monday Night
Football it's it's all it's all nuts on
shows like this the next day when you
say yeah maybe I don't
yeah that's true maybe it's the
perception or the image that Tom Brady
has not because he's from Michigan but
because he's uh he's a good guy and he's
in his he said he's got a good
disposition and he's he's a likable
character and and you see him go cuckoo
like that on the sidelines you you you
you must wonder okay cuz Josh you know
Josh in Bill O'Brien they can they coach
hard alright and so sometimes maybe they
hit a nerve and that's probably what
happened and can you imagine if they
were losing the game I mean they were
winning this game but anyway that
happens once in a while you get there's
so much emotion down there once in a
while if you do hit a nerves like wow
you just fire back all right mooch get a
lozenge I wish I would say I'll be I'll
see you in Atlanta but I guess I was
looking forward to this you know no no
cause it's just listening right now it's
which I wanted to go to Atlanta alright
your service chick-fil-a night that's
why you wanted the chick-fil-a just go
anyway show up yeah I got a flight no
hotel and I you show them crash your
production meetings they're not gonna
kick you out much oh I won't be at the
production meeting Steve I'll be doing
this show maybe I'll come on the show
and do it like another Monday's with
mooch on Thursday
would you do that now we're talking now
let's do that take care yourself mooch
we'll chat soon
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience